before we start um i gave
the same talk at stamford quite recently
um i suggested to the people who invited
me i could just give one talk and both
audiences have come but they will prefer
just two separate talks so if you went
to this talk recently i suggest you
leave now
you won't learn anything new
okay
what i'm going to do is combine some
recent ideas in neural networks
um to try to explain how a neural
network could represent part hole
hierarchies
without violating any of the basic
principles of how neurons work
and i'm going to
explain these ideas in terms of an
imaginary system
i started writing a design document for
a system and in the end i decided the
design document by itself was quite
interesting
so this is just vaporware stuff that
doesn't exist little bits of it now
exist but
um
somehow i find it easy to explain the
ideas in the context of an imaginary
system
so most people now study neural networks
so doing engineering and they don't
really care if it's exactly how the
brain works they're not trying to
understand how the brain works they're
trying to make cool technology
and so 100 layers is fine in a resonant
weight sharing is fine in the
convolutional neural net
um some researchers particularly
computational neuroscientists um
investigate neural networks artificial
neural networks in an attempt to
understand how the brain might actually
work
i think we've still got a lot to learn
from the brain
and i think it's worth remembering that
for about half a century the only thing
that kept research on neural networks
going was the belief that it must be
possible to make these things
uncomplicated things because the brain
does
so
every image has a different parse tree
that is the structure of the holes in
the parts in the image
and in a real neural network
you can't dynamically allocate you can't
just grab a bunch of neurons and say
okay you now represent
this
because you don't have random excess
memory you can't
just set the weights of the neurons to
be whatever you like what a neuron does
is determined by its connections and
they only change slowly at least
probably
mostly they change slowly
um
[Music]
so the question is if you can't change
what neurons do quickly
how can you represent a dynamic position
in symbolic ai it's not a problem you
just grab a piece of memory that's what
it normally amounts to
and say this is going to represent a
node in the past tree and i'm going to
give it pointers to other nodes other
bits of memory that represent other
nodes so there's no problem
for about five years i played with a
theory called capsules
where
you say because you can't allocate
neurons on the fly you're going to
allocate them in advance so we're going
to take groups of neurons and we're
going to allocate them to different
possible nodes in repository
and most of these groups of neurons for
most images are going to be silent
a few are going to be active
and then the ones that are active we
have to dynamically hook them up into a
pause tree so we have to have a way of
routing between these groups of neurons
so that was the capsules theory
and i had some
very competent people working with me
who actually made it work
um but it was
tough going
my view is the side is want to work and
some ideas don't want to work and
captures are sort of in between things
like back propagation just want to work
you try them and they work
um there's other ideas i've had that
just don't want to work um capsules were
sort of in between and we got it working
but i now have a new theory that could
be seen as a funny kind of capsules
model in which each capsule is universal
that is instead of a capsule being
dedicated to a particular kind of thing
each capsule can represent any kind of
thing
but hardware still comes in capsules
which are also called embedding
sometimes
so
the imaginary system i'll talk about is
called glom
and in glom
hardware gets allocated to columns
and each column contains multiple levels
of representation
of what's happening in a small patch of
the image
so within a column
you might have
a lower level representation that says
it's a nostril
and the next level up might say it's a
nose and the next level might say a face
the next level up a person on the top
level might say it's a party that's what
the whole scene is
and the idea for representing part whole
hierarchies is to use islands of
agreement between the embeddings at
these different levels
so at the scene level at the top level
you'd like the same embedding for every
patch of the image because that patch is
a patch of the same scene everywhere
at the object level you'd like the
embeddings of all the different patches
that belong to the object to be the same
so as you go up this hierarchy you're
trying to make things more and more the
same
and that's how you're squeezing
redundancy out
the embedding vectors are the things
that act like pointers and the embedding
vectors
um are dynamic they're neural
activations rather than neural weights
so it's fine to have different embedding
vectors for every image
so here's a little picture
if you had a
one-dimensional row of patches
these are the columns for the patches
and
you'd have something like a
convolutional neural net as a front end
and then
after the front end you produce your
lowest level embeddings that say what's
going on in each particular patch
and so that bottom layer of black arrows
they're all different
of course these embeddings are thousands
of dimensions
um maybe hundreds of thousands in your
brain
and so a two-dimensional vector
isn't right but at least i can represent
where the two vectors are the same by
using the orientation
so the lowest level
all the patches will have different
representations
but the next level up
the first two patches they might be
part of a nostril for example
and so
um
yeah they'll have the same embedding
but the next level up
the first three patches might be part of
a nose
and so they'll all have the same
embedding
notice that even though what's in the
image is quite different
at the part level
those three red vectors are all meant to
be the same
so what we're doing is we're getting the
same representation for things that are
superficially very different
we're finding spatial coherence in an
image
by giving the same representation to
different things
and
at the object level you might have a
nose and then a mouse
and they're the same face they're part
of the same face
and so all those vectors are the same
and this network hasn't yet settled down
to produce on the unseen level
so the islands of agreement
are what capture the past tree now
they're a bit more powerful than a parse
tree they can caps they can capture
things like shut the heck up
you can have shut and up can be
different vectors at one level but at a
higher level shut and up can have
exactly the same vector namely the
vector for shut up
and they can be disconnected so you can
do things a bit more powerful than a
context free grammar here um but
basically it's a parts tree
if you're a physicist
um
you can think of each of these levels as
an icing model
with real valued vectors rather than
binary spins
and you can think of them being
coordinate transforms between levels
which makes it much more complicated and
then this is a kind of multi-level icing
model
but with complicated interactions
between the levels because for example
between the red arrows and the black
arrows above them you need the
coordinate transform between a nose and
a face
but we'll come to that
later if you're not a physicist ignore
all that because it won't help
so i want to start and this is i guess
is particularly relevant for a natural
language course where you some of you
are not vision people
by trying to prove to you that
coordinate systems are not just
something invented by descartes
um
coordinate systems are
were invented by the brain a long time
ago and we use coordinate systems in
understanding what's going on in an
image
i also want to demonstrate the
psychological reality of parse trees for
an image
so i'm going to do this with a
task that i invented a long time ago
um in the 1970s when i was a grad
student in fact
and you have to do this task to get the
full benefit from it
so i want you to imagine on the tabletop
in front of you there's a wireframe cube
and it's in the standard orientation for
a cube
it's resting on the tabletop
and from your point of view
there's a front bottom right hand corner
and a top back left hand corner here we
go
okay
um the front bottom right hand corner is
resting on the table top along with the
four other corners
and the top back left hand corner is at
the other end of a diagonal goes through
the center of the cube
okay so far so good
now what we're going to do is rotate the
cube so that this finger stays on the
table top
and the other finger is vertically above
it like that
this finger shouldn't have moved
okay
so now we've got the cube in an
orientation where that thing that was a
body diagonal is now vertical
and all you've got to do is take the
bottom finger
because that's still on the tabletop and
point with the bottom finger to where
the other corners of the cube are
so i want you to actually do it off you
go take your bottom finger hold your top
finger
at the other end of that diagonal that's
now been made vertical and just point to
where the other corners are
and
luckily zoom so
most of you
other people won't be able to see what
you did and i can see that some of you
aren't pointing and that's very bad um
so
most people
point out four other corners and the
most common response is to say they're
here here here and here they point out
four corners in a square halfway up that
axis
um
that's wrong as you might imagine and
it's easy to see that it's wrong because
if you imagine the cube in the normal
orientation
and count the corners there's eight of
them
and these were two corners
so where did the other two corners go
so one theory is that when you rotated
the cube the centripetal forces made
them fly off into your unconscious
um that's not a very good theory
so
what's happening here
is you have no idea where the other
corners are unless you're something like
a crystallographer
um you can sort of imagine bits of the
cube but you just can't imagine this
structure of the other corners what
structure they form
and this common response that people
give of four corners in a square
is doing something very weird
it's trying to it's saying well okay i
don't know i don't know where the bits
of a cube are um but i know something
about cubes i know the corners come in
fours
i know a cube has this four-fold
rotational symmetry or two planes of
bilateral symmetry but right angles to
one another
and so what people do is they preserve
the symmetries of the cube in their
response
they give four corners in a square
now what they've actually pointed out if
they do that
is two pyramids
each of which has a square base
one's upside down and they're stuck base
to base
so you can visualize that quite easily
it's a square based pyramid with another
one stuck underneath it and so now you
get your two fingers as the vertices of
those two pyramids
and
what's interesting about that is
you've preserved the symmetries of the
cube at the cost of doing something
pretty radical which is changing
faces to vertices and vertices to faces
the thing you pointed out if you did
that was an octahedron
um it has eight faces and six vertices
a cube has six faces and eight vertices
so in order to preserve the symmetries
you know about of the cube
you've if you did that you've
done something really radical which has
changed faces for vertices and vertices
for faces
um
i should show you what the answer looks
like
so i'm going to step back and try and
get enough light and maybe you can see
this cube
so this is this is a cube
and
you can see that
the other edges
form a kind of zigzag ring around the
middle
so i've got a picture of it
so the colored rods here are the other
edges of the cube the ones that don't
touch your fingertips
and your top fingers connected to the
three vertices of those flaps
and your bottom fingers
connected to the lowest three vertices
there
and that's what a cube looks like it's
something you had no idea about
this is just a completely different
model of a cube it's so different i'll
give it a different name i'll call it a
hexahedron
and
the thing to notice is a hexahedron and
a cube are just conceptually utterly
different you wouldn't even know one was
the same as the other if you think about
one as oxygen one as a cube
it's like the ambiguity between a tilted
square and an upright diamond but more
powerful because you're not familiar
with it
um
and that's my demonstration that people
really do use coordinate systems and if
you use a different coordinate system to
describe things and here i forced you to
use a different coordinate system by
making the diagonal be vertical and
asking you to describe it relative to
that vertical axis
then familiar things become completely
unfamiliar
and when you do see them relative to
this new frame they're just a completely
different thing
notice that things like convolutional
neural nets don't have that they can't
look at something and have two utterly
different internal representations of
the very same thing
i'm also showing you that you do parsing
so here i've colored it so you pass it
into what i call the crown
which is three triangular flaps that
slope upwards and outwards
here's a different parsing
the same green flap soaking upwards and
outputs now we have a red flap sloping
downwards and outwards and we have a
central rectangle and you just have the
two ends of the rectangle
and if you know if you perceive this
and now close your eyes and ask you were
there any parallel edges there
you're very well aware that those two
edge two blue edges were parallel and
you're typically not aware of any other
parallel edges even though you know by
symmetry there must be other pairs
similarly with the crown if you see the
crown
and then i ask you to close your eyes
and ask you were the parallel edges you
don't see any parallel edges
and that's because the coordinate
systems you're using for those flaps
don't line up with the edges and you
only notice parallel edges if they line
up with the coordinate system you're
using
so here for the rectangle the parallel
edges align with the coordinate system
for the flaps they don't
so you're aware that those two blue
edges are parallel but you're not aware
that one of the green edges in one of
the registers is parallel
um
so this isn't like the neca cube
ambiguity where when it flips you think
that what's out there in reality is
different things are at a different
depth
this is like
next weekend we shall be visiting
relatives
so if you take the sentence next weekend
we shall be visiting relatives it can
mean
next weekend what we will be doing is
visiting relatives or it can mean next
weekend what we will be is visiting
relatives
now those are completely different
senses
they happen to have the same truth
conditions they mean the same thing in
the sense of truth conditions because if
you're visiting relatives what you are
is visiting relatives
and it's that kind of ambiguity no
disagreement about what's going on in
the world but two completely different
ways of seeing the sentence
so
this is um this was drawn in the 1970s
this is what ai was like in the 1970s
this is a sort of structural description
of the crown interpretation
so you have nodes for the all various
parts in the hierarchy
i've also put something on the arcs that
rwx
is the relationship between the crown
and the flap
and that can be represented by a matrix
it's really the relationship between the
intrinsic frame of reference of the
crown than the intrinsic frame of
reference of the flap
and notice that
if i change my viewpoint that doesn't
change at all
so that kind of relationship would be a
good thing to put in the weights of a
neural network because you'd like a
neural network to be able to recognize
shapes independently of viewpoint
and that rwx is knowledge about this
shape that's independent of viewpoint
here's the
zigzag interpretation
and here's something else where i've
added
the things in the heavy blue boxes
they're the relationship between
the
a node and the viewer
that is to be more explicit the
coordinate transformation between the
intrinsic frame of reference of the
crown and the intrinsic frame of
reference of the viewer
your eyeball is that rwv
and that's a different kind of thing
altogether because as you change
viewpoint that changes
in fact as you change your viewpoint all
those things in blue boxes all change
together in a consistent way
and there's a simple relationship which
is that if you take rwb
then you multiply it by rwx you get rx v
um so
you can easily propagate viewpoint
information over a structural
description
and that's what i think a mental image
is
rather than a bunch of pixels
it's a structural description with
associated viewpoint information
um
that makes sense of a lot of properties
of mental images like
if you want to do any reasoning with
things like rwx you form a mental image
that is you fill in you choose a
viewpoint
and i want to do one more demo to
convince you you always choose a
viewpoint when you're solving mental
imagery problems
so i'm going to give you another very
simple mental imagery problem at the
risk of running overtime um
imagine that
you're at a particular point and you
travel a mile east and then you travel a
mile north and then you travel a mile
east again
what's your direction back to your
starting point
this isn't a very hard problem
it's sort of a bit south and quite a lot
west right
it's not exactly southwest but it's sort
of south west
now when you did that task what you
imagined
from your point of view
is you went a mile east and then you
went to mile north and then you went to
mile east again
i'll tell you what you didn't imagine
you didn't imagine that you went to mile
east and then you went to our north and
then you went to mile east again you
could have solved the problem perfectly
well with north not being up
but you had north up
you also didn't imagine this you go mile
east and then a mile north and then a
mile east again
and you didn't imagine this you go mile
east and then a mile north and so on you
imagined it at a particular scale in a
particular orientation in a particular
position
that's
and you can answer questions about
roughly how big it was and so on so
that's evidence that to solve these
tasks that involve using
relationships between things you form a
mental image
um okay enough on mental imagery
so i'm now going to give you a very
brief introduction to contrastive
learning
so where this is a complete
um
disconnect in the talk but i'll come
back together soon
um
so
in contrast to self-supervised learning
what we try and do is make two different
crops of an image have the same
representation
um
there's a paper a long time ago by becca
and hinton where we were doing this to
discover low level coherence in an image
like the continuity of surfaces
or
the depth of surfaces
um
it's been improved a lot since then and
it's been used for doing things like
classification that is
you take
you take an image that has one prominent
object in it
and you say
if i take a crop of the image that
contains sort of any part of that object
it should have the same representation
as some other crop of the image
containing a part of that object
and
this has been developed
a lot in the last few years i'm going to
talk about a model developed a couple of
years ago my group in toronto called
sinclair but there's lots of other
models and since then things have
improved
so in simclair you take an imagex
you take two different
crops and you also do color distortion
of the crops different color distortions
of each crop
and that's to prevent it from using
color histograms to say they're the same
um so you mess with the color so it
can't use color
in a simple way
and
that gives you
x i tilde and xj tilde
you then put those through the same
neural network f
then you get a representation h
and then you take the representation h
and you put it through another neural
network which compresses it a bit
it goes to low dimensionality
um that's an extra complexity i'm not
going to explain but it makes it work a
bit better
you can do it without doing that
and you get two embeddings zi and zj
and your aim is to maximize the
agreement between those vectors
and so you start off doing that and you
say okay let's
start off with random neural networks
random weights in the neural networks
and let's take two patches and let's put
them through through these
transformations and let's try and make z
i be the same as zj so let's back
propagate the squared difference between
components of i and components of j
and hey presto
what you discover is um everything
collapses
um
for every image
it will always produce the same zi and
zj
and then you realize well that's not
what i meant by agreement i mean they
should be the same
when you get two crops of the same image
and different when you get two crops of
different images
otherwise it's not really agreement
right
um
so you have to have negative examples
you have to show it crops from different
images and say those should be different
if they're already different
you don't try and make them a lot more
different
it's very easy to make things very
different but that's not what you want
you just want to be sure they're
different enough so crops from different
images aren't taken to be from the same
image so if they happen to be very
similar you push them apart
and that stops your representations
collapsing that's called contrastive
learning
and it works very well
so
what you can do is do unsupervised
learning
by trying to maximize agreement between
the
representations you get from two image
patches from the same image
and after you've done that you just take
your representation of the image patch
and you feed it to a linear classifier a
bunch of ways so that you multiply the
representation by a weight matrix put it
through a softmax
and get class labels
and then you train that by
gradient descent
and
what you discover is that that's just
about as good as training on labeled
data
so now the only thing you trained on
label data is that last linear
classifier the previous layers were
trained on unlabeled data
and
you've managed to train your
representations without needing labels
[Music]
now there's a problem with this
um it works very nicely
but it's really confounding objects and
whole scenes
so it makes sense to say two different
patches from the same scene
should get the same
vector label at the scene level because
they're from the same scene
but what if one of the patches contains
bits of objects a and b and another
patch contain bits of objects a and c
you don't really want those two patches
to have the same representation at the
object level
so we have to distinguish these
different levels of representation
and for contrastive learning
if you don't use any kind of gaiting or
attention
then what's happening is you're really
doing learning at the seam level
what we'd like is that the
representations you get at the object
level
should be the same
if both patches or patches are object a
but should be different if one patches
from object and one patches for object b
and to do that we're going to need some
form of attention to decide whether they
really come from the same thing
and so glom is designed to do that it's
trying to take contrastive learning
and to introduce attention of the kind
you get in transformers
in order not to try and say things are
the same when they're not
i should mention at this point that most
of you will be familiar with bert
then you could think of the word
fragments that are fed into bert as like
the image patches i'm using here
and in bert you have that whole column
of representations of the same word
fragment
in but what's happening presumably as
you go up is you're getting um
semantically richer representations
but in bert there's no attempt to
get representations of larger things
like whole phrases
this what i'm going to talk about will
be a way to modify burps so as you go up
you get bigger and bigger islands of
agreement
so for example
after a couple of levels
then things like new and york
will have the different fragments of
york suppose he's got two different
fragments we'll have exactly the same
representation if it was done in the
glom right way
and then as you go up another level
the fragments of new well news probably
a thing in its own right but and the
fragments of york would all have exactly
the same representation
um they'd have this island of agreement
and that would be a representation of
a compound thing and as you go up you're
going to get these islands of agreement
that represent bigger and bigger things
and that's going to be a much more
useful kind of bird because instead of
taking
vectors that represent word fragments
and then sort of mung them together by
taking the max of each for example the
max of each component for example which
is just a crazy thing to do
you'll explicitly as you're learning
form representations of larger parts in
the part hole hierarchy
okay
so what we're going after glo england is
a particular kind of spatial coherence
that's more complicated than the spatial
coherence caused by the fact that
surfaces tend to be at the same depth
and same orientation in nearby patches
of an image we're going after the
spatial coherence
um
that says that
if you find a mouth in an image and you
find a nose in an image and then the
right spatial relationship to make a
face
then that's a particular kind of
coherence and we want to go after that
unsupervised
and we want to um discover that kind of
coherence in images
so before i go into
more details about glom i want a
disclaimer
um
for years computer vision treated vision
as you've got a static image a uniform
resolution and you want to say what's in
it
um that's not how vision works in the
real world in the real world this is
outer loop where you decide where to
look
if you're a person or a robot
um
you better do that intelligently
and
that that gives you a sample of the
optic array it turns the optic array the
incoming light
into a retinal image and on your retina
you have high resolution in the middle
and low resolution around the edges
and
so you're focusing on particular details
and you never ever process the whole
image at uniform resolution you're
always focusing on something and
processing where you're fixating at high
resolution and everything else at much
lower resolution particularly around the
edges
so i'm gonna
ignore all the complexity of how you
decide where to look and all the
complexity of how you put together the
information you get from different
situations
by saying let's just talk about the very
first fixation on a novel image so you
look somewhere and now what happens on
that first fixation
we know that the same hardware in the
brain is going to be reused for the next
fixation
but let's just think about the first
fixation
so finally here's a picture of the
architecture
and this is
the architecture
for a single location so like for a
single word fragment in bert
and
it shows you what's happening for
multiple frames so glom is really
designed for video but i only talk about
applying it to static images
then you should think of a static image
as a very boring video in which the
frames are all the same as each other
so
i'm showing you three adjacent levels in
the hierarchy
and i'm showing you what happens over
time
so if you look at the middle level
maybe that's the sort of major part
level
and look at that box that says level l
and that's at frame four
um so the right hand level l box
and let's ask how the state of that box
is the state of that embedding is
determined
so inside the box we're going to get an
embedding
and the embedding is going to be the
representation of what's going on at the
major part level
for that little patch of the image
and level l
in this diagram all of these embeddings
will always be devoted
to the same patch of the retinal image
okay
the level l embedding
on the right hand side
you can see there's three things
determining it there there's a green
arrow
and for static images the green arrow is
rather boring it's just saying you
should sort of be similar to the
previous state of level l so it's just
doing temporal integration
the
blue arrow
is actually a neural net with a couple
of hidden layers in it i'm just showing
you the embeddings here not all the
layers of the neural net
we need a couple of hidden layers to do
the coordinate transforms that are
required
and the blue arrow
is basically taking information at the
level below
of the previous time step
so level l minus one on frame three
might be representing that i think i
might be a nostril
well if you think you might be a nostril
what you predict at the next level up is
a nose what's more
if you have a coordinate frame for the
nostril you can predict the coordinate
frame for the nose maybe not perfectly
but you have a pretty good idea of the
orientation position scale of the notes
so that bottom up neural net
is
a net that can take any kind of part at
level and minus when you take a nostril
but it could also take a steering wheel
and predict the car from the steering
wheel um
and predict what you've got at the next
level up
the red arrow is a top down neural net
so the red arrow
is predicting
the
nose from the whole face
and again it has a couple of hidden
layers do coordinate transforms
because if you know the chord the
coordinate frame of the face
and you know the relationship between a
face and a nose
and that's going to be in the weights of
that top down neural net
then you can predict
the that it's a nose and what the pose
of the nose is
and that's all going to be in activities
in that embedding vector
okay
now there's all of that is what's going
on in one column of hardware that's all
about a specific patch of the image
so that's very very like what's going on
for one word fragment in bert you have
all these levels of representation
um
it's a bit confusing exactly what the
relation of this is to bert and i'll
give you the reference to a long
archived paper at the end that has a
whole section on how this relates to but
um but it's confusing because this has
time steps um
and that makes it all more complicated
okay
um
so those are three things that determine
the level of embedding
but there's one fourth thing
which is in black at the bottom there
and that's the only way in which
different locations interact
and that's a very simplified form of a
transformer
if you take a transformer
as invert and you say let's make the
embeddings and the keys and the queries
and the values all be the same as each
other
we just have this one vector
so now
all you're trying to do
is make the level l embedding in one
column be the same as the level l
embedding in nearby columns
but it's going to be gated you're only
going to try and make it be the same
if
it's already quite similar
[Music]
so here's how the attention works
um you take the level l embedding in
location x that's alex
and you take the level l embedding in
the nearby location y that's our y
you take the scalar product
you exponentiate
and you normalize in other words you do
a soft max
and that gives you the weight to use
in
your desire to make
lx be the same as l y
so the input produced
by this
um
from neighbours
is an attention weighted average of the
level and embeddings of nearby columns
and that's an extra input that you get
it's trying to make you agree with
nearby things and that's what's going to
cause you to get these islands of
agreement
so back to this picture
i think um
yeah
this is what we'd like to see
and the reason
um we get those
that big island of agreement at the
object level
is because we're trying to get agreement
there we're trying to learn the
coordinate transform
from the red arrows to the level above
and from the green arrows to the level
above such that we get agreement
okay
now one thing we need to worry about
is that the difficult thing in
perception
um
is not so bad in language it's probably
worse than visual perception is that
there's a lot of ambiguity
if i'm looking at a line drawing for
example i see a circle
well a circle could be the right eye of
a face or it could be the left eye of a
face or it could be the front wheel of a
car or the back wheel of a car there's
all sorts of things a third circle could
be
and we'd like to disambiguate the circle
and there's a long line of work
um using things like markov random
fields here we need a variation on a
microphone field which i'll call a
transformational random field
because the interaction between for
example something that might be an eye
and something that might be a mouse
needs to be gated by corner transforms
you know for the let's take a nose and a
mouth because that's my standard thing
if you take something that might be a
nose and you want to ask does anybody
out there support the idea on my nose
well what you'd like to do is send
to everything nearby a message saying
um
do you have the right kind of pose
and right kind of identity to support
the idea that i'm a nose
and so you'd like for example to send
out a message from the nose you'd send
out a message to all all nearby
locations saying does anybody have a
mouth with the pose that i predict by
taking the pose of the nose multiplying
by the coordinate transform between the
nose and the mouth and now i can predict
the pose of the mouse is is there
anybody out there with that pose who
thinks they might be a mouse
and i think you can see you're gonna
have to send out a lot of different
messages
um
for each kind of other thing that might
support you you're gonna need to send a
different message so you're gonna need a
multi-headed
transformer
and it's going to be doing these
coordinate transforms
and you have to transform the inverse
transform on the way back
because if the mouse supports you it
what it needs to support is a nose um
not with the pose of the mouth but with
the appropriate pose
so that's going to get very complicated
you can have n squared interactions all
with coordinate transforms
there's another way of doing it that's
much simpler it's called a half
transform
at least it's much simpler if you have a
way of representing ambiguity
so instead of these direct interactions
between parts like your nose and mouth
what you're going to do is you're going
to make each of the parts
predict the hole
so the nose can predict the face
and it can predict the pose of the face
and the mouth can also predict the face
now these will be in different columns
of glom but in one column column you'll
have a nose predicting face
in a nearby column you'll have a mouth
predicting face
and those two faces should be the same
if this really is a face
so when you do this attention weighted
averaging with nearby things what you're
doing is you're getting confirmation
that
um the support
for the hypothesis you've got i mean
suppose in one column you make the
hypothesis it's a face with this pose
that gets supported by nearby columns
that derive the very same embedding
from quite different data one derived it
from the nose and one derived it from
the max
and this doesn't require any dynamic
routing
because the embeddings are always
referring to what's going on in the same
small patch of the image
within a column there's no routing and
between columns
there's something a bit like routine but
it's just the standard transformer kind
of attention you're just trying to agree
with things that are similar
and
okay so that's how glom's meant to work
and the big problem is
that if i see a circle it might be a
left right it might be a right eye it
might be a
front wheel of a car it might be the
back wheel of a car
because my embedding for a particular
patch at a particular level has to be
able to represent anything
when i get an ambiguous thing i have to
deal with all these possibilities of
what hole it might be part of
so instead of trying to resolve
ambiguity at the part level what i'm
going to do is jump to the next level up
and resolve the ambiguity there just by
seeing if things are the same
which is an easier way to resolve
ambiguity
but the cost of that is i have to be
able to represent all the ambiguity i
get at the next level up
now it turns out you can do that we've
done a little
toy example
where
you can actually preserve this ambiguity
um
but it's difficult it's the kind of
thing neural nets are good at
so if you think about the embedding in
the next level up
you've got a whole bunch of neurons
whose activities are that embedding
and you want to represent
a highly multi-modal distribution like
it might be a car with this pose or a
car with that pose or a face with this
pose or a face with that pose
all of these are possible predictions
from finding a circle
and so you have to represent all that
and the question is can your let's do
that
well i think the way they must be doing
it is
each neuron in the embedding
stands for an unnormalized log
probability distribution
over this huge space of possible
identities and possible poses
the sort of cross product of identities
and poses
um
and so the neuron is this rather vague
log probability distribution over that
space
and when you activate the neuron what
it's saying is add in that log
probability distribution to what you've
already got
and so now if you have a whole bunch of
log probability distributions
and you add them all together
you can get
a much more peaky log probability
distribution
and when you exponentiate you get a
probability distribution it gets very
peaky
and so very vague basis functions
in this joint space of pose and identity
and basis functions in the log
probability of that space
can be combined to produce sharp
conclusions
so
i think that's how neurons are
representing things most people think
about neurons as
they think about the thing that they're
representing
but obviously in perception you have to
deal with uncertainty and so neurons
have to be good at representing um
multimodal distributions
and this is the only way i can think of
that's good at doing it
that's a rather weak argument
and it's the argument that led chomsky
to believe that language wasn't learned
because he couldn't think of how it was
learned
my view is neurons must be using this
representation because i can't think of
any other way didn't it
okay
i just said all that because i got ahead
of myself because i got excited um
now the reason you can get away with
this the reason you have these very
vague distributions in the unnormalized
low probability space
is because
these neurons are all dedicated to a
small patch of image
and they're all trying to represent the
thing that's happening that patch of
image
so you're only trying to represent one
thing you're not trying to represent
some set of possible objects
if you're trying to represent some set
of possible objects you'd have a
horrible binding problem and you
couldn't use these very vague
distributions but so long as you know
that all of these neurons all of the
active neurons refer to the same thing
then you can do the intersection you can
add the log probability distribution
together and intersect the sets of
things they represent
okay i'm getting near the end how would
you train a system like this
well obviously you could train it the
way you train but you could do deep
end-to-end training
um
and for golomb
what that will consist of and the way we
trained a toy example
is you
take an image
you leave out some patches of the image
you then let glom settle down for about
10 iterations
and it's trying to fill in
the lowest level representation of the
what's in the image
the lowest level embeddings
and
it fills them in wrong and so you now
back propagate that error and you're
back propagating it through time in this
network so it'll also back propagate up
and down through the levels
um
so you're basically just doing back
propagation through time
of the error due to filling in things
incorrectly
that's basically how
bird is trained and you could train glom
the same way
but i also want to include an extra bit
in the training
to encourage islands
um
we want to encourage
um
big islands of identical vectors at
higher levels
and you can do that by using the trust
of learning
so if you think how the next
at the next time step if you think how
an embedding is determined
it's determined by combining
a whole bunch of different factors
what was going on in the previous time
step
at this level of representation in this
location
what was going on at the previous time
step
in this location but of the next level
down
at the next level up
and also what was going on at the
previous timestep at nearby locations
at the same level
and
the weighted average of all those things
i'll call the consensus embedding and
that's what you use for the next
embedding
and i think you can see that
if we try and make the bottom up neural
net on the top down neural net if we try
and make their predictions agree with
the consensus
the consensus has folded in
information from nearby locations
um that already roughly agree because of
the attention rating
and so by trying to make the top-down
and bottom-up neural networks agree with
the consensus
you're trying to make them agree with
what's going on nearby locations that
are similar and so you'll be training it
to form islands
um
this is more interesting to
neuroscientists than to people who do
natural language so i'm going to ignore
that
um
you might think it's wasteful to
be replicating
all these embeddings at the object level
so the idea is at the object level
there'll be a large number of patches
that all have exactly the same vector
representation
and that seems like a waste but actually
biology is full of things like that all
your cells have exactly the same dna in
and all the parts of an organ have
pretty much the same vector protein
expressions so there's lots of
replication goes on in
to keep things local
and it's the same here and actually that
replica replication is very useful when
you're settling on an interpretation
because before you settle down
you don't know which things should be
the same as which other things so having
separate vectors in each location to
represent what's going on there at the
object level gives you the flexibility
to gradually segment things as you
settle down in a sensible way
um it allows you to hedge your bets
and what you're doing is not quite like
clustering you're creating clusters of
identical vectors rather than
discovering clusters in fixed data so
clustering you're given the data and
it's fixed and you find the clusters
here
the embeddings at every level
are
variable they vary over time they're
determined by the top-down and bottom-up
inputs and by inputs coming from nearby
locations so what you're doing is
forming clusters rather than discovering
them in fixed data
and that's got a somewhat different
flavor
and can settle down faster
and one other advantage this replication
is
what you don't want is to have much more
work in your transformer as you go to
higher levels
but you do need longer range
interactions at higher levels presumably
for the lowest levels you want fairly
short range interactions in your
transformer and they could be dense as
you go to higher levels you want much
longer range interactions so you could
make them sparse
and people have done things like that
for
bird-like systems
here it's easy to make them sparse
because you're expecting big islands so
all you need to do is see
one patch of a big island to know what
the vector representation of that island
is
and so sparse representations will work
much better if you have these big
islands of agreement as you go up so the
idea is you have longer ranges faster
connections as you go up so the amount
of computation is the same in every
level
and just to summarize
um
i showed how to combine three important
advances of neural networks in glom i
didn't actually talk about neural fields
and that's important for the top-down
network maybe since i've got two minutes
to spare i'm going to go back and
mention neural fields very briefly um
yeah when i train that top-down neural
network
i have a problem
and the problem is
if you look at those red arrows and
those green arrows
they're quite different
but if you look at the level above the
object level
all those vectors are the same
and of course
in an engineered system i want to
replicate the neural nets in every
location so i use exactly the same top
down in modern neural nets everywhere
and so the question is how can the same
neural net
be given a black arrow
and sometimes produce a red arrow and
sometimes produce a green arrow which
have quite different orientations
how can it produce
a nose where there's nose and a mouth
where there's max even though the face
vector is the same everywhere
and the answer is
the top-down neural network doesn't just
get
the face vector it also gets the
location of the patch for which is
producing
the part vector
so the three patches that should get the
red vector are different from the
different locations from the three
patches that should get the green vector
so if i use the neural network that gets
the location as input as well
here's what it can do
it can take the pose that's encoded in
that black vector the pose of the face
it can take the location
in the image
for which is predicting the vector of
the level below
and the pose is relative to the image
too so knowing the location in the image
and knowing the pose of the whole face
it can figure out which bit of the face
it needs to predict at that
location
and so in one location you can predict
okay there should be nose there and it
gives you the rib vector in another
location it can predict from where that
image patch is there should be mouth
there so it can give you the green arrow
so you can get the same vector at the
level above to predict different vectors
in different places level below by
giving it the place that it's predicting
for and that's what's going on in neural
fields
okay
um
now this was quite a complicated talk
there's a long paper about it on archive
that goes into much more detail
um and you could view this talk as just
an encouragement to read that paper
when i'm done
exactly on time
okay thank you so great thanks a lot
you